احد اسباب التدهور يوم 7/4 الرئيس ظهر
يعني امام العالم
وقال يعني قول يعني المعروف مشهور اذا
اعتدت علينا اسرائيل او قصفت العراق او
الاردن اعتقد احرق نص اسرائيل هذا ازعج
الامريكان واقام الدنيا وما اقعدها بعد
بيوم 13 بالشهر اخبرني قال انا كنت
بالموصل يعني فتره الربيع قال فاخبرني
السكرتير
قال لي وفد امريكي جاي والوفد يقوده
السناتور بوب دول وطبعا بوب دول يعني كان
من السناتره من الصقور
ماكين وبزن
جون
يعني الاخرين
قال ارسلت لهم طائره الخاصه وجابوهم هم
اربع اشخاص ومعهم سفيره
فالتقيت وياهم قال كان اول ما يعني حدثوني
كان بحده بعتب شديد على موضوع التصريح انه
ايش حرق نصف اسرائيل بالضبط انه هذا يعني
هيج العالم كله يعني هيج العالم كله ضد
العراق فايش كان مريضه
التصريح وهل انت جاد يعني بهذا التصريح
جاد بالفعل يعني ترجمه الواقع
وكان عندهم عده مطالب منها هيكله الجيش
العراقي انه دخلت
ب 15 فرقه وطلعت ب 60 فرقه ومنها لانه
يعني قويه كثيرا الجيش
حتى الدول العربيه قال من عندك خمس قاده
عرب